[Music]
I love that I get to make exposing the
truth about something a part of my
[Music]
job I had this new language to describe
things that for my whole life I thought
were just
normal like the way that some men
treated me and my body that was actually
ass
salt or my touchy feely grandpa is is
actually a
pedophile when I watch these tapes I see
a man with a serious problem who knows
that he's not going to get
[Music]
caught was there anybody that you ever
felt like you could talk to about
[Music]
it do you feel like God has forgiven you
absolutely
it's hard to forgive someone who doesn't
ask for
forgiveness my stuff I went through it's
never as big as what you've had to go
through of course I feel responsible
she's my kid and I've always wanted to
protect
her if you stay angry and can't forgive
somebody you're drinking the poison
yourself you've got to let go I would
like to not have my relationship with my
mom
and I'm writing to you as you may have
been a past patient of William
Flickinger and I'm in the process of
seeking accountability for my
grandfather's
actions if I can be the one to step
forward and on the record say he did
this you can't deny it it's the very
least that I can
[Music]
do